you came up with the idea for as the
dust settles right you want to tell us
just in a nutshell yeah what was the
plan for the collaboration with these 25
or so people in the beginning yeah it
was I mean it was like yeah I talked
about as a snowball effect was just like
one thing led to the next quicker and
quicker and quicker back in two thousand
six and seven I was seeing all these
amazing photographs of color and art and
people out on the playa at Burning Man
and I was like wow this is fascinating
from a photographer's perspective it
it's beautiful and so I was like wow you
know we could take some red cameras out
there and make an amazing documentary
kind of this profound documentary and so
I basically was like yeah you know let's
go out there let's go out there and so I
kind of asked a bunch of people and I
asked a bunch of people there was this
tribe calm and asked friends of friends
hey you know what kind of documentary
should be done and so this idea of sort
of having a bunch of people with their
own cameras adopt documenting their own
experiences would be really profound and
interesting and that idea kind of led me
to invite a bunch of director friends of
mine and they ended up inviting their
friends and their friends and so we were
calling the project or participatory
project which was sort of like hey be
involved if you want to this is what's
going to happen and yeah ultimately you
know the day before we went out to the
playa we had 25 people that were that
were involved back in two thousand eight
and they all met at your place here in
LA yeah yeah so we had people from the
east coast New York Connecticut etc we
had people from Reno we had people from
Northern California with people from Los
Angeles and everything kind of came out
here to Los Angeles we loaded up all the
gear and then we picked up a bunch more
people in like the reno area and all
went out to the playa and you so you
traveled as a caravan or you had one
vehicle yeah we rented a friend's RV
with a massive u-haul trailer and
which took another vehicle as well so we
had I think 18 or 19 people all going
from the Los Angeles area and we picked
up another three cars or so in Reno and
forgive me I've never been to Burning
Man or at least not yet where are you
staying once you're there what what is
this a tent burning in burning my owns a
dry lake bed and it's nothing and then
it becomes the event and it becomes a
city when we were there there was almost
50,000 people there this year I think
there was close to 70,000 people so it's
sort of like it's it's desert camp it
says it's a desert camping trip and so
you're going to have the full range of
people you're going to have people that
are tent camping you're going to have
people that are you know car camping
you're going to people with massive RVs
your kind of people with a you know air
conditioned massive trailer you know you
know deluxe living accommodations euro
vans yeah yeah and I'm sorry this is
2008 yeah this is right before sort of
the market and everything took a dive
but things were sort of precarious this
was August September 2008 yeah so there
everything was kind of okay you know it
was it was after that actually in 2009
there was actually less attendance than
in 2008 which is interesting look
because Burning Man now is sold out
which is interesting but in 2009 there
was actually a drop in the people put so
you have 25 or so collaborators in the
end you were made with five well we have
a full team so its up on up on the team
page on our website in the end you know
we you could say I don't know 18 19
people all still involved there's
there's five collaborating directors
that are in the final cut of the film
the way we really the way the way we
finished it so you know I think
it was very interesting to see how it
all came together because some some of
these people I had basically just met
the day before we went out shooting
which is which is did you know how do
you how do you do a project with people
you don't know and don't know how much
you can trust and don't know their
skills well that was the beauty of the
project the beauty of the project was
that we had a mixture we had a mixture
of people that knew how to shoot amazing
cinematographers that came out the shoot
with the red cameras we also had a bunch
of people that never shot a single frame
and some of those people ended up being
the most interesting and their stories
of the most profound you know a mixture
Roger Ingram is one of the collaborating
directors he had a film out at Sundance
back in 2006 and so working with him and
working with some of the other people
involved it was it was like you know we
can do this we're all were all making
this thing together
you